or one of the great things that is
lacking in most of our companies is that
they are not teaching us how to lead and
leadership is a skill like any other is
a practice' balloon able skill and it is
something that you work on it's like a
muscle if you practice it all the days
you will get good at it and you will get
become a strong leader if you stop
practicing you will become a weak leader
like parenting everyone has the capacity
to be a parent doesn't mean everybody
wants to be a parent
and doesn't mean everybody should be a
parent leadership is the same we all
have the capacity to be a leader doesn't
mean everybody should be a leader and it
doesn't mean everybody wants to be a
leader and the reason is because it
comes at great personal sacrifice
remember you're not in charge you're
responsible for those in your charge
that means things like when everything
goes right you have to give away all the
credit and when everything goes wrong
you have to take all the responsibility
that sucks right it's things like
staying late to show somebody what to do
it's things like when something does
actually break when something goes wrong
instead of yelling and screaming and
taking over you say try again when the
overwhelming pressures are not on them
the overwhelming pressures are on us at
the end of the day great leaders are not
responsible for the job they're
responsible for the people who
responsible for the job
[Music]